we're told the following table shows a
few inputs and outputs of function g all
right we have some possible inputs here
for x and then the corresponding outputs
here g of x
what is the value of g inverse of 54
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out before we work through
it together
all right let's just remind ourselves
what an inverse function even does
so if you have some value x and you
input it into some function g
that function is going to output g of x
and an inverse function takes us the
other way we could take this what was
the output of g g of x we can input that
into an inverse function the inverse
function of g and that is actually going
to give us
x it's going to get us back to our
original input right over here
so what we're focused on right over here
is g inverse of 54. so we can think
about this part of this little chain
that we set up
so what we're inputting into this
inverse function is 54.
so what we want to say is all right
when g of x is equal to 54 what is x and
we can see that right over here when g
of x is 54 the corresponding input
original input one way to think about it
is 62. so this will be equal to 62. now
some of you might have been tempted to
say okay look it looks like i'm
inputting a 54 into a function so i'll
say okay x is the input let me just go
to 54 right over there as the input but
remember this 54 isn't an input into the
inverse of g this is an input into g of
x
so if you wanted to evaluate this if you
wanted to evaluate
g of 54
then you would look at the 54 up here
and say okay that's going to be equal to
65 but we're looking at the inverse of g
so one way to think about it is
when 54 is the output in g
what is going to be the input and we see
that that is 62.